we're going to begin with breaking news
five U.S citizens have been moved from
an Iranian prison to house arrest as
part of a deal between the U.S and Iran
they include Iran's longest-serving
American prisoner xiaomik namazi he was
charged in 2015 for having quote
relations with a hostile State it's the
initial part of an agreement involving
the eventual release of billions of
dollars of Iranian funds Frozen in South
Korea Mike Hannah's monitoring
developments for us in Washington D.C
might what's the U.S been saying about
this
well they've welcomed the steel the
National Security Council spokesperson
saying that these people should not have
been imprisoned in the first place also
pointing out that this is the beginning
of what is likely to be a lengthy
process before these prisoners secure
their final release now the swap
involves a number of Iranians being held
in prison in America and as well and
this is a complicating Factor some 8
billion dollars in Iranian funds that
were confiscated and were being held in
South Korea now part of this delay is
going to be figuring out the logistics
of getting those funds back to Iran Iran
making clear that this deal will not go
ahead until that money is back in its
coffers now this deal is multinational
that involves Oman Qatar Switzerland all
of whom have been involved in the
negotiations and getting this money back
from South Korea to Iran it appears it
will go back through Qatar and then get
transferred from there so a very
complicated process but none less both
the state department and the National
Security Council welcoming the fact that
the process is now moving forward with
the removal of these prisoners from
prison to house arrest Mike thank you
very much Mike Hannah talking to us from
Washington DC we're going to go to
dosage of body she's joining us with the
latest from the Iranian Capital Tehran
does I understand of course that it's
the weekend there but has there been any
sort of reaction from Iran about this
no we have not heard from any officials
so far
um but we have been hearing from local
media and state TV that have been
broadcasting this news and quoting the
Western media reports that have come out
over the past few hours but we have been
hearing from the Iranian foreign
minister over the past few weeks and
most recently we heard from Amir
Abdullahi on Tuesday who reiterated that
Iran has been swapping messages with the
United States through Oman and Qatar
regarding this prisoner swap and that it
was going to be based on humanitarian
grounds and no preconditions would be
set but it appears now that there are
some very difficult conditions that Iran
has set being the release of six billion
dollars of Frozen funds in South Korea
and of course this is money that Iran
has owed
um and the South Koreans have been
holding on to it since 2018
as a result of U.S sanctions for the oil
and gas that they've been purchasing
from Iran uh this is a very significant
development first of all because it
provides an opportunity for both Iran
and the United States to seize this
chance to break this cycle of escalation
that we've been seeing over the past few
years and we heard from the reports
regarding these negotiations that
they've been ongoing for two years so
this is an opportunity for both
countries to show that they have the
political will to move past their
differences and to forge a more common
ground that leads to de-escalate the
tensions that have been ongoing in this
region over the past few years dorsa
thank you very much Dr Jabari from
Iran's Capital Tehran